le lac de l'Abbaye est un des trésors du
Jura un paysage a coupé le souffle alors
pour aider les touristes à mieux le
comprendre à mieux l'interpréter la
communauté de communes de grand
Vallières a fait appel à une équipe de
paysagistes et d'architectes
devant un paysage sublime comment aller
au-delà du simple éblouissement comment
guider le regard de celui qui n'est que
de passage c'est pour répondre à ces
questions que les élus de la communauté
de communes la grandvallière se sont
adressés à Yolande Guilloton et à
lin-brustel si le visiteur baisse les
yeux il sentira comment le parvis se
prolonge jusqu'au lac des empreintes
d'oiseaux lui indiqueront le chemin
possible par petites touches la
paysagiste à structurer l'espace sans
imposer de parcours
on espère effectivement que ça va
interroger ou au moins inciter les
visiteurs à garer leur véhicule et puis
aller un petit peu plus loin d'autant
que s'ils vont jusque sur jusqu'à ce
parvis devant ils pourront voir
disséminés dans le paysage des signaux
des signaux qui ont été conçus comme des
objets architecturaux dans le paysage
comme des éléments voilà d'interrogation
au loin on aperçoit une sorte de petite
tour elle est indiquée sur un plan c'est
le silo à images
même si tout n'est pas encore bien
fléché le touriste peut désormais
cheminer autour du lac à travers champ
le promeneur se dirige vers ce drôle de
cylindre des surprises la tend à
l'intérieur
comment faire une réalisation qui permet
d'avoir une lecture de paysage et en
même temps
d'être surélevé c'était cette idée
d'avoir ce cylindre qui a été construit
avec les matériaux bruts de la région
forcément puisque notre objectif c'est
donner avoir aussi ce qu'on sait faire
dans le dans le Haut Jura et que le
matériau dû au Jura les 360 degrés nous
permettent d'avoir la lecture complète
du paysage avec tous les thèmes qui sont
déclinés et à partir du moment où vous
voyez la fenêtre vous avez dessous ou
dessus la lecture qui explique ce que
vous voyez exactement à travers cette
fenêtre
cette réalisation du lac de l'abbaye est
l'un des 70 sites jurassiens répertoriés
dans ce guide de l'architecture moderne
et contemporaine en Franche-Comté ce
livre est un mine d'or pour tous ceux
qui aiment se balader tout en cherchant
à comprendre l'envers du décor
bienvenue au lac des rouges truites dans
le parc naturel du Haut-Jura la commune
est propriétaire à 80% d'un Village de
Vacances Le Domaine du Bugnon les élus
ont demandé à Alain brustel et à ses
associés d'imaginer des cabanes
volontairement rustiques mais tout
confort à l'intérieur
on a l'impression qu'elle vienne d'être
construites faut dire qu'il y a pas si
longtemps que ça
un coup d'oeil assez super
troisième exemple avec cette fois-ci une
autre drôle de tour on l'appelle la
kaborde donc ici on est dans un lieu
bien particulier du Jura on est
exactement au pied du Revermont le
revers du Mont d'un côté le plateau avec
la petite montagne et de l'autre la
braise duracienne
là aussi l'agence d'architecte a été
choisie pour son audace la communauté de
communes du Sud Revermont voulait
pouvoir accueillir aussi bien les
touristes que les habitants du secteur
avec trois mots clés culture tourisme et
Terroirs il y a une part d'invention
c'est-à-dire on cherche à
intriguer à donner l'envie d'aller à
l'intérieur vous avez un mouvement de
double escalier en hélice qui en serre
le bâtiment on a l'impression qu'il
renferme quelque chose de précieux et en
même temps il filtre un peu les vues à
travers une résine boisée qui est qui
qui va un petit peu dans cette idée de
mystère à l'intérieur de cette kaborde
contemporaine dégustation originale de
vin salle de projection et d'expo se
décline sur les trois niveaux les gens
sont toujours surpris par la dimension
architecturale intérieure extérieure on
nous pose beaucoup de questions sur la
présence du bois qui est prédominante
l'architecture est faite pour être vue
mais elle donne aussi à voir sur la
terrasse de la kaborde c'est encore un
tableau naturel qui attend le visiteur